IC, or the information coefficient,
is just the correlation of the manager's
forecast to actual returns.
So for instance, if she made a forecast
on IBM, that it would go up 1%,
and it went up 0.5%, well,
it's a positive correlation.
This value can range from 0,
where the correlation is not present,
to 1, where it's very, very strong.
Finally, BR, or
breadth, represents the number of
trading opportunities per year.
So for example, if you're Warren Buffet,
and you hold 120 stocks, and
you just hold them all year,
that's 120 trading opportunities.
If, say, you're Jim Simons, and
you trade 100,000 times per day,
you multiply that times the number
of trading days in a year, well,
it turns out to be a very large number.
Key thing is, even if it's just
a portfolio where you buy and
hold, you count the number of positions
in that portfolio as the number of
trading opportunities, because this
is oriented around an annual measure.